[Music]
foreign
i want to tell you my secret now
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i see dead people
in your dreams
while you're awake
did people like in graves and coffins
walking around like regular people
joseph listen to me
sometimes when people get sick or hurt
for a long time
like elijah their mind gets hurt too
when they start to think things that
aren't true he told me what he thought
about your father
it isn't true i'll show you
do you remember the story about the
about the boy that almost drowned in the
pool
that was me they were talking about i
almost died that was me
i'm not lying okay i just didn't
remember it that's all you know your
father was injured in college you know
that you know all about that
don't do it he'll die joseph shoot him
once
joseph listen to what you're
don't be scared
joseph if you pull that trigger i'm
going to leave
do you understand i'm going to go to new
york
you're right if you pull that trigger
that bullet is just going to bounce off
me and i'm not going to be hurt
but then i'm going to go upstairs and
i'm going to pack and i'm going to leave
for new york why because i thought we
were just starting to be
friends for real and friends listen to
each other they don't
and they don't shoot each other do they
audrey
and no shooting friends joseph
joseph you are about to be in big
trouble
now i am your father and i am telling
you to put that goddamn gun down right
[Music]
now
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
no don't let them
in
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
reggie reggie reggie just keep looking
in his eyes
keep looking in his eyes
something in this field could be
releasing the chemical into the air when
there's too many of us together
let's just stay ahead of the wind
let's just break up into groups
so
here it comes
don't you let go of my head
[Music]
[Music]
don't be afraid
uh
[Music]
i need you to do a physical assessment
you are showing rapid blood
contamination
are you cut i'm dizzy
guitar self-evil
come on
i can't stand open your medkit you are
going to have to administer the
antitoxin in sequence
inject yourself with the clear liquid
first do it now
i can't see the poison is affecting your
nervous system stay even
dad please come help me i can't see
i can't do this for myself bad please
don't forget me
inject yourself directly into your heart
with the first stage
do it now
you play hide and seek down here there's
um there's lots of visual tension
mom's hiding seek place
you better hide my ethnically confused
friend
one mississippi two
mississippi three mississippi
four mississippi five mississippi
ready or not here i come
i see you you little pudge
i'll have to use strategy he's faster
but i'm smarter by at least two standard
deviations
don't do that don't do that he can't
handle reality
my name is jade has dr fletcher been
getting our emails
this is what we have to do we as in 1008
when ana de paula suffered the shahi's
most crushing defeat and mahmoud overran
the entirety of the punjab reason taking
the famed temple of congress we have
been wronged by
this alliance this hoard of patricia
dennis and the boy
their actions do not represent us they
are every everybody just take a minute
oh baby girl they've been stealing
control of their life for me but the
group
are gonna work through this honey my
name is barry
you shouldn't have used the
walkie-talkies
what's upsetting you patricia what if he
can't do
these extraordinary things
what if he is just unwell
like you
everything extraordinary can be
explained away
and yet it is true
i think deep down you know this
everything we will see and do will have
a basis in science
but it will have limits this is the real
world not a cartoon
and yet some of us don't die from
bullets
some of us can still bend steel
that is not a fantasy
if you really think you can get us all
out
then you may meet the beast but for your
sake
i hope he likes you
tomorrow night color
board meeting or whatever
what do we call you sir
first name mister last name
glass
[Music]
you